[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour je suis Aline Wirtz j'ai 29 ans
et je me bats tous les jours contre
moi-même pour atteindre mes rêves
vendredi 24 février j'ai froid j'ai faim
et j'en peux plus de cette longue
journée j'ai envie de rentrer
je suis couché sur le sol froid de mon
CrossFit complètement détruite de mon
entraînement
ça fait trois heures que je suis là et
j'en peux plus
son côté classé sur de ce matin m'a déjà
volé mon âme
non mais 20h30 j'ai vraiment envie de
rentrer mais qu'est-ce que je fais
encore là
j'ai encore dehors sur ma programmation
je vais pas pouvoir je suis vidée et
j'en ai marre ça mène à quoi de faire
tout ça pourquoi je fais ça
je vais jamais y arriver
stop stop
je me bats pour ça et jamais je
n'aimerais un jour ne plus avoir mon
révé en tête jamais je veux comment les
mon objectif peu à pour ce que ça me
demande je me lève je prends ma barre et
j'ajoute du poids
je respire et je commence mon prochain
workout car je veux gagner
je suis sûr que ce genre de situation
parle à beaucoup d'entre vous on a tous
ce genre de moments on a plus envie la
motivation elle est plus là on a quand
même une petite voix dans notre tête qui
nous dit qu'il faut faire un pas plus il
faut quand même y aller et du coup on le
fait et cette petite voix c'est la
discipline
la discipline c'est quoi la discipline
en général peut être perçue comme un
ensemble de règles un ensemble de normes
qu'on décide de suivre parfois aux
dépendante de volonté
on peut penser à des exemples flagrants
comme par exemple aux soldats à l'armée
ou alors aux études ou au travail ou
c'est normal d'être discipliné c'est
normal tu arrives à l'heure bien pressé
pause de suivre une ligne de conduite
prescrite par le supérieur l'entreprise
ou la société en général c'est normal
mais si finalement il suffisait de
suivre un certain nombre de règles pour
pouvoir atteindre ses rêves les plus
fous pourquoi est-ce que seulement une
minorité en sont capables
la véritable question c'est pourquoi
est-ce que la plupart des gens
n'arrivent pas à être disciplinés pour
atteindre le rêve car pour commencer il
faut trouver cette fameuse source
d'inspiration cette chose qui nous anime
et qu'on a vraiment au plus profond de
soi c'est la motivation intrinsèque
c'est d'ailleurs en ayant cette
motivation intrinsèque en ligne de mire
qu'on est capable de prendre des
décisions chaque jour en fonction de
cette dernière
dans notre société
ultra standardisée c'est normal d'aller
à l'école de faire des études ou un
apprentissage de trouver un métier qui
nous fasse gagner notre vie se mettre en
ménage acheter une maison food une
famille c'est un peu ce que la société
attend nous et c'est ce pourquoi on a
toujours été de brûlé
cette vie d'ailleurs correspond à la vie
de rêve du plus grand nombre mais qu'en
est-il des autres
qu'en est-il des personnes qui sont pas
parfaitement à l'aise dans cette société
ou dans ce genre de style de vie
beaucoup d'entre nous ont cherché et
cherchent encore à rentrer dans l'Iran
de cette société sans vraiment y
parvenir
d'ailleurs je tiens à préciser que je ne
critique pas la société ni ce qu'elle
prône étant donné qu'elle va contenter
le plus grand nombre mais ce que je
regrette en revanche avec ça c'est que
bon nombre d'entre nous vont se
retrouver en quelque sorte piégé dans un
moule qui a pas vraiment ajusté à eux
finalement on y reste car on se dit que
c'est mieux que rien on n'a pas envie de
sortir de la normalité on veut pas trop
créer de vagues
mais est-ce qu'il n'existerait pas
quelque chose à côté de cette vie bien
normée qui nous fasse véritablement
vibrer
est-ce que vous avez jamais pensé par
exemple à faire un Iron Man ou alors à
escalade et l'Everest ou à créer votre
propre entreprise je suis sûr que oui on
a tous des rêves
d'ailleurs si maintenant je vous
demandais de prendre 15 secondes pour
définir quel est votre rêve est-ce que
vous en serez capable vous avez
maintenant ces 15 secondes à vos
dispositions
qui d'entre vous a réussi à définir son
rêve dans ses 15 secondes
ok pour ces personnes là sachez que vous
avez déjà atteint la première étape pour
y parvenir pour les autres pas de
panique c'est normal de pas savoir quel
est notre motivation intrinsèque cette
chose qu'on a vraiment au fond de nous
c'est difficile de savoir quel est son
rêve le plus fou
mais comme on a vu avant c'est vraiment
on est en sort l'une de mire qu'il est
possible de prendre des décisions chaque
jour en fonction de ce dernier sans cela
on peut s'appuyer sur la motivation mais
là aussi on l'a vu au début la
motivation c'est quelque chose qui va
qui vient qui éphémère et du coup il
faudrait quelque chose de beaucoup plus
solide pour pouvoir atteindre un rêve
quelque chose qui est vraiment ou qui
paraît inaccessible et ça c'est la
discipline
personnellement j'ai toujours pratiqué
énormément de sport
j'ai toujours j'ai commencé la
gymnastique à 6 ans j'ai ensuite fait de
l'athlétisme de l'escalade du volet
plein de sport d'endurance marathon
triathlon vélo de route j'ai tout essayé
j'ai toujours été super motivé pour tous
mes sports mais j'ai jamais vraiment
hâte d'excellence
jusqu'au moment où j'ai compris que pour
atteindre l'excellence il fallait avoir
la discipline à partir du moment où vous
comprenez que seul la discipline pourra
vous mener là où vous avez envie d'aller
et que vous désirez atteindre votre au
moins autant que vous avez besoin de
respirer ce jour là la question n'est
plus de savoir est-ce que je vais y
arriver
mais quand
là où la société me voit un peu comme
une personne extrême je me considère
comme une personne complètement dévouée
et passionnée pour atteindre ses rêves
la société dans laquelle on vit elle va
pas nous interdire
de vouloir arriver à ses rêves de
vouloir parvenir à ses buts par contre
elle va pas forcément nous y encourager
non plus et c'est donc de notre
responsabilité de se battre au quotidien
pour ça
des jours où la motivation et au plus
haut j'ai l'impression que je pourrais
soulever n'importe quel bar à mon
entraînement j'ai l'impression de tout
survoler évidemment heureusement il y en
a beaucoup mais ce sont justement les
jours où tout est difficile ou tout est
pénible que ma discipline va être un
véritable atout c'est cette discipline
qui va me permettre de faire des choses
que j'ai pas forcément envie de faire
sur le moment mais qui pourtant
correspond à ma motivation initiale et
c'est cette décision qui nous sépare du
plus grand nombre
bienvenue dans mon combat ce sérieux
conflit interne entre la facilité c'est
à dire le plaisir à court terme et la
difficulté le résultat à long terme
ce que beaucoup considèrent comme des
sacrifices je le considère comme un
investissement un investissement
personnel qui me permet de me rapprocher
de mes rêves car la voix facile ne paie
jamais bien
moi aussi malheureusement j'entends
cette petite voix dans ma tête qui
parfois me dit de tout arrêter de tout
abandonner de tout plaquer que jamais je
parviendrai à mes rêves
mais je me rappelle constamment quel
genre de personne j'ai envie d'être une
gagnante et les gagnants sont
disciplinés une gagnante serait prête à
tout pour atteindre ses rêves
évidemment ça serait beaucoup plus
facile de dire qu'on a ça dans notre ADN
ou qu'on l'a pas
mais ça serait aussi un joliment songe
qu'on se fera à nous-mêmes pour se
rassurer surtout pour nous dédouaner
face à la responsabilité des décisions
qu'on prend quotidiennement
car la vérité fait mal
et cette vérité c'est qu'on a tous le
choix des décisions qu'on va prendre
chaque année chaque mois chaque semaine
chaque jour chaque heure et chaque
minute
quand on pense à son objectif final
c'est clair qu'on a le sentiment qu'il
est inaccessible impossible à atteindre
il est beaucoup trop lointain
mais en fait c'est à ce moment là que
tout se joue c'est à ce moment là que la
partie va continuer ou que le jeu
s'arrête
au final ce qui nous empêche d'avancer
ce qui nous retient sur place ce sont
nous
ce sont nos insécurités
nos peines sont nos doutes ils nous
enchaîne sur place et son prêt à nous
mettre KO
pour ne pas qu'on aille de l'avant et
pour pas qu'on continue pourtant cet
ennemi il est loin d'être invincible
si la vie est un jeu elle possède des
règles pour définir qui gagne et qui
perd
et ces règles doivent suivre une logique
précise pour déterminer les conditions
du jeu en fait aussi simple que ça le
but évidemment c'est de gagner c'est à
dire d'arriver au bout de sa partie à la
ligne d'arrivée la date de son objectif
final
chaque joueur possède un certain nombre
de cartes en main qu'il est libre de
jouer comme ils le souhaitent
c'est-à-dire une par une ou en créant
des combinaisons les unes avec les
autres et ce choix lui appartient
entièrement
le joueur il est autorisé d'avancer
s'immobiliser reculer parfois avec la
chance sauter de plusieurs cases en
avant
pour avoir une chance de gagner la
partie
c'est nécessaire de jamais abandonner
sinon c'est une défaite comme dans
beaucoup d'autres jeux
du coup ça paraît si facile pourquoi
est-ce que pas tout le monde le gagne
seul une minorité est capable de gagner
car il y a très peu de personnes qui
sont capables d'aller jusqu'au bout de
leur partie sans abandonner
dans ce jeu on a plusieurs cartes à
disposition
chacune a un rôle bien défini mais
ensemble elle forme un toutes ensemble
elles vont former votre identité et
c'est de votre responsabilité de savoir
comment vous les jouez et comment vous
les appréhendez
vos réactions et vos actions face à ces
cartes vont définir les prochaines
étapes de ce jeu
voici quelques exemples de cartes
inspiration motivation comportement
enthousiasme habitude
échec peur adversité et la principale
discipline
sans savoir j'ai décidé de jouer à ce
jeu il y a de cela bien longtemps
et cette carte discipline j'en connais
désormais son pouvoir
aujourd'hui vous avez en face de vous
une personne qui a décidé de suivre son
cœur pour atteindre ses rêves
j'aimerais pouvoir rassurer ou apaiser
la conscience des personnes qui disent
que cette fille elle a toujours dû être
comme ça mais au risque vous surprendre
c'est pas le cas il y a quelques temps
si j'avais pu me fasser le long des murs
si j'avais pu creuser un tunnel de 10
mètres de profondeur pour me cacher et
pas qu'on voit je leur ai fait je suis
pas né en ayant cet esprit de battante
c'est quelque chose que j'ai appris à
construire jour après jour
comme la plupart des gens j'ai été
influencée parce que la société
attendent non
consciemment ou à consciemment j'ai été
de rilier à devenir une jeune femme
discrète qui se fond dans le décor et
surtout qui prend pas trop de place
qui d'entre vous aurait pu imaginer que
cette jeune fille ici à gauche malade au
point de se faire hospitaliser mal dans
sa peau au point de vouloir disparaître
Graham après Graham puisse un jour se
retrouver devant une audience de plus de
100 personnes pour parler d'un sujet tel
que la discipline pas grand monde
qui d'entre vous aurait pu se dire un
jour que c'est d'une fille de 30 kg qui
n'a à peine debout puisse un jour être
sollicité plusieurs fois par semaine
pour des Conseils de nutrition pour des
conseils de force et de confiance en soi
là non plus pas grand monde
qui d'entre vous aurait pu imaginer que
cette jeune fille puisse un jour se
classer parmi les meilleurs athlètes de
sa catégorie
personne
personne n'aurait pu imaginer que cette
jeune fille à la dérive puisse un jour
devenir une jeune femme fière de
chercher son bonheur personnel
fier de se battre au quotidien pour
atteindre ses rêves et fier de venir
d'essayer de venir la meilleure version
d'elle-même
je suis encore très loin d'arriver à la
fin de ma partie est-ce que j'aimerais
partager aujourd'hui avec vous c'est
cette volonté de continuellement
chercher à le faire
la discipline va pas seulement nous
permettre d'atteindre nos rêves la
discipline va bien au-delà de ça chaque
action chaque décision que vous prenez
chaque jour va influencer le cours de
votre vie
aucun de vous ne devrait un jour se dire
que vous trêve est inaccessible niveau
ni cette jeune fille la différence entre
la majorité des gens et ceux qui ont
décidé de se battre pour le rêve se
trouve ici c'est la discipline c'est
l'unique carte que vous aurez en main
qui vous permettra de gagner votre
partie ou au moins de vous en rapprocher
pour gagner la partie il faut comprendre
qu'on n'aura jamais une main parfaite en
début de jeu il faut comprendre et
surtout accepter de jouer avec ces
cartes regardez les combinaisons qu'on
peut faire les unes avec les autres en
fonction des cartes et parfois accepter
qu'on n'aura pas le choix de
s'immobiliser voire même de reculer et
ce plusieurs fois pendant une même
partie
un gagnant doit être capable de tenir
des parties interminables même s'ils se
trouvent en dernière position avec une
main qui est pas parfaite tout en
sachant pertinemment que l'arrivée est
loin
la différence entre un gagnant et un
perdant ne se trouve pas dans les cartes
que chacun reçoit la différence c'est la
discipline
une personne qui veut gagner sa partie
ne va pas écouter la voix qui prône la
facilité elle va se battre au quotidien
pour atteindre ses buts ses objectifs et
ses rêves pour devenir la meilleure
version d'elle-même même si elle sait
que ça sera difficile
la jeune femme que vous avez en face de
vous a décidé un jour de ne plus se
contenter de survivre dans un moule qui
était mal ajusté à elle mais de se
battre pour serrer au quotidien
j'ai pas la garantie et j'aurais jamais
la garantie d'y parvenir mais j'aurais
au moins la chance d'avoir essayé de le
faire et d'avoir suivi mon cœur
on a tous une histoire et on reçoit tous
un certain nombre de cartes en main
début de partie la carte discipline se
trouve dans la main de chacun d'entre
vous et c'est désormais de votre
responsabilité de savoir si vous voulez
la jouer et comment vous voulez la jouer
samedi 25 février
il est 21h30 j'ai froid j'ai faim et je
suis exténuée de cette longue journée
stressante où j'ai dû parler devant
plein de monde
j'ai envie de rentrer
mais qu'est-ce que je fais là
ah oui je suis en train de gagner la
partie
et dans votre partie
qui mène le jeu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]